So today we're going to continue to
talk about a cardiac physiology in
particular, the electrophysiology
of the heart, which is,
which is quite interesting and
important to, uh, heart function.
And also one of the,
uh,
it turns out that one of the
most important diagnostic
measurements that can be
made, uh, is, uh,
through a device that was designed by
biomedical engineers called an electric
cardiograph.
And so we'll talk about today sort of
the origins of electrical activity in the
heart, the role that this
electrical activity plays in
the function of the heart.
And then finally,
how we'll talk a little bit about how
one can measure that electrical activity,
which comes from cells in the heart,
sort of deep inside your body but can be
measured with electrodes on the surface
of your body.
And you'll get some more experience with
making those measurements in a section
on Thursday afternoon. So this is, uh,
I apologize,
a rather complicated diagram,
but I wanted to show you a picture
that would give you a sense for,
uh, sort of, uh,
where the electrical potential
that all cells have comes from.
And you know that cells are bathed in an
extracellular fluid and that that extra
cellular fluid contains molecules
including ions are charged molecules.
In fact, the extra cellular fluid
is very rich in a particular ions,
sodium and has lesser
amounts of other ions.
Uh,
potassium and calcium are the three most
important in the electrical activity of
membranes, sodium, potassium and calcium.
So the extra cellular space,
which is up on the top here is filled
with those ions in particular has a high
concentration of sodium.
The intracellular space are inside the
cell also is a water rich environment and
also has ions.
But the ion composition inside the
cell is different than the composition
outside the cell in that the sodium
concentration is relatively low.
And so this chart here shows you for a
typical cell sodium concentration might
be 15 millimolar while the extracellular
sodium concentration is 145 millimolar.
Okay,
so almost 10 fold higher sodium ion
concentration outside the cell than inside
the cell.
Well now you know from what you know about
the structure of lipid membranes that
charged molecules,
even though they're small charged ions,
like sodium cannot penetrate
through a lipid biolayer.
So there's no way for sodium to
get through this lipid bi layer.
So even though there's a very
large difference in concentration,
okay,
uh,
these molecules of sodium on the outside
can't diffuse inside because they can't
permeate through the
Lipid biolayer right now,
cal or potassium notice has a very
high concentration inside the cell,
120 millimolar, and outside the
cell, the concentration is low,
4.5 millimolar. So again, a big
difference in potassium concentration,
but going in the opposite direction,
if the membrane was permeable,
sodium would diffuse in and
potassium would diffuse out,
but it can't through a
plane. Lipid biolayer well,
you also know that cell membranes
are not just lipid bilayers.
They have proteins inserted in them.
And we talked about proteins that serve
as as receptors, right? For example,
the insulin receptor that
binds to insulin. All right.
And we talked about signal transduction
through those receptors a few weeks ago.
We also talked briefly about the fact
that some of these proteins are transport
proteins and their role
in the cell membrane is to
allow molecules that the cell
needs to come in or to go out and the
glucose transporter is an example of that,
right?
So the only way that glucose can get
inside cells to provide a substrate for a
metabolism is because there
are specialized proteins
in the membrane that allow
glucose to cross in the same way.
They're a specialized proteins that allow
ions to cross and these proteins come
in two varieties.
Some are active transport
proteins like this one,
which is called the sodium potassium
pump and it's actually a little machine
that sits inside the cell membrane.
It's a protein base machine and its job
is to pump a pump sodium out of the cell
and potassium into the cell.
Sodium goes out, potassium goes in,
and it's, it's moving those molecules
against their concentration gradients.
And so energy is required for that to
happen. It doesn't happen spontaneously.
You can't move molecules.
Molecules don't spontaneously moved from
regions of low concentration to high
concentration. So it requires energy
and it gets its energy from ATP.
So this is called the sodium potassium
pump and, and it's ubiquitous in,
in cells throughout the body and it's
how cells maintain this low sodium
concentration and high
potassium concentration
inside is because of they have
these little machines in their membranes
that are continually uh, pumping, uh,
sodium and potassium in.
Does that make sense?
And so it's the action of this pump
that causes these differences in ions to
occur.
There are other proteins that serve as
channels and you can think of these as
very specialized pores,
pores in the membrane that allow ions
to pass through and they're selective at
this one is a potassium channel.
And so if it is open,
it allows potassium to pass through.
It only allows passive transport.
It's not a machine like the other one,
it's just a,
it's just a portal or a hole that
allows potassium to move down its
concentration gradient.
So if this potassium channel is open,
then potassium will naturally move
and it will move from high to low
concentration.
That is,
it'll move from inside the
cell to out if sodium has,
if there's a channel per sodium and it
happens to be open and that's what this
is showing here.
A channel with the lid off
means the channel is open,
then sodium can pass from its high
concentration to low concentration or from
the extra cellular space to the
intracellular space, right? So the,
the sale is in a dynamic equilibrium that,
and it's sort of,
it's sort of steady state,
its natural state.
There is this active machine
that's pumping sodium out
and potassium in and then
there are these pores that when they
exist and when they're open are letting
these molecules to leak
back the other way.
So the pump always has to be operating
because the leak is always happening.
Does that make sense?
Because you have these differences
in ion concentrations across the cell
membrane,
these and you have the,
the the flux of molecules continuously
across the membrane in that,
what I've shown here are channels
that are, they have a lid on them.
So there's some times open
and sometimes closed, right?
They can be both open and closed,
but every cell in your body at a given
time is going to have lots of potassium
channels that are open and lots
of sodium channels that are open.
Okay.
There just some that are open all
the time. And because of that,
there's a continual leakage of potassium
out of the cell and it continual
leakage of sodium into the cell.
Well,
if ions are moving
across the cell membrane,
ions are charged molecules and
that movement is a current, right?
You usually think of currencies, movements
of electrons, but movements of ions of,
of positively charged
ions is also current.
So there's a continual current flow
across the membrane and that continual
current flow causes a potential
difference across the membrane.
Now a membrane that's at rest that is
in its resting state is going to have a
given number of channels of sodium
and potassium that are open.
And so there'll be a given current of
sodium that's flowing in and given certain
certain, uh, uh, um,
current of potassium that's flowing out.
And that's being compensated
by the activity of this pump,
right? But this current flow
creates a potential or voltage.
So just like a battery because
these currents are flowing.
If I measured the electrical potential
on both sides of these men, uh, of these,
uh, of this membrane, I would
get a voltage difference.
And it turns out that for most cells
that voltage differences negative,
the inside of the cell is
slightly negative compared to the,
to the outside of the cell and it's
in the range of minus 60 to minus 90
millivolts. Okay, so that's the backdrop.
That's what you should think of as sort
of the resting state of a membrane.
It has these channels in it,
it exists in this,
in this a fluid environment where there's
high sodium outside high potassium
inside current flows,
membrane potential generated
to make it more complicated.
There are certain of these ion channels
that exist in open and closed states and
those open and closed states are regulated
by the voltage across the membrane.
And here's one called the voltage
dependent sodium channel and the resting
state.
When the membrane voltage is,
let's say minus 90 millivolts,
the channel is closed.
And so this channel does not
allow for sodium to enter.
If it opens,
sodium now can enter through these new
channels and if there are a lot of these
voltage gated channels on
the surface and the and the,
and they sense a change in
voltage and they all open,
one can have a dramatic change in the
currents that flow through the membrane
and hence the dramatic change
in membrane potential. Okay.
Now that's exactly what happens
when we have an action potential.
And I show you this diagram that I
showed you a few weeks ago when we were
talking about the nervous system and how
it communicates and I explained it in
sort of a superficial way then,
but now you can understand it a little
better if you think about it in terms of
these of the membrane and the membrane
having channels that allow sodium and
potassium to flow.
So under resting condition they have
a population of channels that's always
allowing sodium and potassium to
flow that creates the potential.
And then they have special channels that
open when the voltage is disturbed in
some way.
And so here we're looking at a trace of
membrane voltage of membrane potential
in time.
And so imagine that you're very small
and you're sitting on the surface of this
membrane,
but you have special shoes on that measure
the voltage or something so you can
experience the voltage,
the potential drop across the membrane
by just standing on this membrane and
you're standing there
in the resting state.
So you're watching sodium and potassium
go by because of their normal fluxes and
the potential that you
measure is say minus,
I showed here is about minus 75
millivolts. Now something happens,
there's some disturbance
in the membrane near you,
not right where you're standing,
but near you.
There's a disturbance and that
disturbance might be a number of events,
but what we've thought about so far is
that there's a neurotransmitter that that
binds somewhere upstream of you that's
in neurotransmitter that binds to a
receptor and it creates a
change in membrane potential,
a small change in membrane potential,
but you feel it
when you feel it at your site.
There's also these voltage sensitive
sodium channels that exist in the membrane
around you. And they go from the
closed state to the open state
in response to this small disturbance,
some new channels open.
These happened to be sodium channels.
They open a lot of them open because
there's a lot of them on your cell because
your cell is designed
to respond to voltages.
So it has a lot of
these kinds of channels.
Now what happens when all
these new sodium channels open,
there's a rush of sodium from
outside the cell to inside the cell.
Sodium is positively charged.
You get a rush of current going
by you and that rush of current,
MMM
depolarizes the membrane.
Remember I said the neck,
the membrane was had a negative potential.
It's more negative on
the inside than outside,
but all of a sudden you've opened all
these sodium channels and a rush of sodium
goes in a rush of positively
charged molecules, go into the cell,
make the inside of the cell less
negative because you're adding a lot more
positive charge to it.
That event is called deep polarization.
And if you were standing on the
cell with your magic boots that were
electrically active,
somehow you would,
you would experience this dramatic
change in membrane potential.
The membrane becoming a lot
less negatively charged,
even positively charged.
And that's do totally to this rush of
sodium through these new channels that
have opened. Well, there's a
second set of channels called uh,
called potassium voltage gated
potassium channels that also opened,
but they're slower than
the sodium channels.
And when they open they allow a lot more
potassium to rush the other way because
remember potassium is high
insight on low outside.
So first you get a rush of
current going in one direction,
then you get a rush of
current going in the other.
And what that causes in terms of membrane
potential is a rapid depolarization
and then a rapid repolarization and
these channels eventually close again and
the membrane returns to its resting state.
If you don't understand all the
details of that, that's fine.
It's described in the book
and also described in other
membrane physiology books
that you could,
you could go to.
It's not important that you
understand all the details,
but do you have a sense for
what's happening is that
within this small region of
the cell membrane we on, there was
some kind of a small disturbance.
It opened all these voltage gated
channels caused rushes of current,
which changed the membrane potential.
And that is in this case what I've
described to you as an action potential,
a small change here causes a
large change at my local site.
And then I pass that on this way,
right?
Because I'm now standing at the site
where there's a huge disturbance in
membrane potential and that's going to
cause some current to flow a little bit
to flow downstream.
And that little bit that flows downstream
is going to cause the voltage gated
channels here to open an action
potential to be generated at this site.
And if you follow that line of thinking
than an initial disturbance over here
creates a massive membrane potential here,
which moves to here,
which moves to here.
And that's an action potential
being transmitted down in neuron.
Right.
Makes Sense.
So that's what we talked about when
we're talking about the nervous system.
We were talking about information
flowing from dendrites,
dendrites that have, uh,
receptors for neurotransmitters,
those receptors for neurotransmitters
causing a small membrane disturbance,
which then gets converted
into an action potential.
And that action potential moves down
the Axon saying this direction to that
direction.
Okay,
why doesn't it move back?
Why does it only move in one direction?
What turns out is very
interesting physiology that
when, when these membrane, uh,
when these voltage gated
membrane channels get opened,
they become, uh, they become, uh,
incapable of being reactivated
for some period of time.
So the voltage gated sodium channels open,
they close, and then they can't be
opened again for some period of time,
just a few milliseconds,
but long enough for the action potential
to pass them out of their region.
Okay?
So that you don't get
currents that flow like,
or action potentials that flow like this.
They only flow in one direction
because these channels need to recover.
Okay.
But, but you understand now a little bit
more about why action potentials flowed
down, uh, down axons. And
when they reach these Termini,
the accident x, the Axon
Termini, what do they do? This,
this sudden change in membrane potential,
activates a new process and
that new process is release
of neurotransmitter from
the synapse.
That neurotransmitter then
activates another cell
generating an action potential,
sending it down its Axon and so on.
Okay.
And so in the nervous system,
messages pass from
neurotransmitter to action,
potential neurotransmitter
action, potential
neurotransmitter action potential.
And because there might be many
neurons impinging on one particular one
particular neuron that I'm interested in
and some are sending positive messages,
some are sending negative messages,
sending these little disturbances, right?
Whether this axon generates
an action potential or not,
depends on the sum total of the small
disturbances that is receiving at any one
time.
And so neurons can integrate information,
right?
And that information is acquired from
all the neurotransmitters that are
impinging on the dendrites that cause
small disturbances that may or may not add
up to the large disturbance,
which becomes an action potential.
You go on to study neuroscience or just
physiology, you'll learn more about this.
Uh, but, but I think you can probably
understand the basic concept.
So in the action potential on a neuron,
we were thinking about his cell that
had a receiving end that receives
neurotransmitter inputs,
that that causes membrane potentials to
change that somehow decides to initiate
an action potential.
And then action potential flows very
rapidly down this specialized process
called an Axon, reaching the axon
terminal [inaudible] and then, uh,
and then neurotransmitters
are released to the next sale.
Heart cells are the same
in that they contain these,
uh, they contain these
special voltage gated, um,
uh, membrane channels. These,
these voltage gated ion channels that
allow for an action potential to form.
They're capable of doing an action
potential because they have these voltage
gated sodium and potassium channels.
Okay.
So because of that,
okay,
heart muscle cells fall into the same
category as nervous of neurons and that
they're in the general category
called excitable cells.
They're excitable cells means they're
capable of making an action potential.
And to have an action potential,
they need to have these specialized
voltage gated ion channels in their
membranes.
So Cardiac myocytes have that.
They also have actin and Myosin,
their muscle cells,
and they're capable of contracting.
Okay.
They're capable of contracting,
meaning that this myocyte
here can shorten itself.
It can make itself shorter by contracting,
just like a muscle,
a whole muscle contracts. Um, and um,
so that's different than neurons,
right? So they have this capacity to,
to transmit action potentials.
They have this capacity to
contract now in muscle cells,
as we'll see in a few minutes,
those things are linked.
When a muscle cell experiences an
action potential, it doesn't do it.
A nerve cell does,
which is passed that information along
to another cell via neurotransmitters.
Instead,
it contracts
experiences the action
potential and it contracts.
It also passes along the action potential,
but it doesn't do that through a
chemical synapse. Like in neurons.
It does it through an electrical synapse
and that these cells are very tightly
welded together.
Okay.
Remember we talked about
in nerve nervous system,
the two cells don't physically touch.
There's a space in between them that's
called the synapse and it's over this
synapse,
that neurotransmitter's act.
They're released from the
presynaptic cell and they,
and they create a change
in the post synaptic cell,
but cardiac myocytes are
basically welded together.
And in fact there are special junctions
called gap junctions in between them
that allow the easy flow of current.
And so if an action potential flows
through this myocyte from this end to the
other, it doesn't have to, it can, it,
it basically flows straight into the
next cell because they're directly
electrically coupled.
And so if an action potential arises
and comes from this direction, it, it,
it flows very quickly down this membrane.
It causes this cell to contract,
it flows right into the next cell,
causing this cell to contract
flows right into the next cell.
Okay.
Causing it to contract.
And so in cardiac muscle,
wherever the action potential starts,
it contracts first.
Then the action potential flows
into the neighboring cells.
They can tract neighboring cells,
they can traction.
So you can think about
the cardiac myocardium,
the sheet that I showed you last time,
the muscular walls of the heart as being
sort of a sheet of these cells that are
all connected to each other and if I
start an action potential in one space,
it's going to flow over the surface and
as it flows over the surface cells will
be contracting right behind it.
Right?
So electrical flow followed
immediately by contraction locally.
Does that make sense? Will you
could imagine that this, this,
now this because they're directly
electrically coupled signals can pass very
quickly over the surface of the heart.
That can pass very quickly
from one to another.
So I just need to start an
action potential in one place.
It'll be propagated everywhere, but
I might like to control that. Right?
Because I'd like to have the heartbeat
function in this controlled fashion we
were talking about last time.
And so how does the heart solve this
problem of control of how this wave of
action potential moves over
the surface of the heart?
Yeah.
What does that through a specialized
group of pathways that are collectively
called the cardiac conduction system.
And this is a terrible diagram.
I'm going to show you the next one.
I'll show you a little bit better than
the next one so you'll see it, but,
but imagine too, so just look at
the surface here. This is the heart,
the left ventricle, the left atrium,
the right ventricle, the right atrium.
And there's this pathway.
There's the heart has something like a
nervous system and that this black region
here is a pathway that's
called the cardiac conduction
system and it consists of
several important points.
The first is called the
sinoatrial node or essay node,
and it's in the right atrium. The
sinoatrial node is in the right atrium.
Uh, the next point is the
atrial ventricular node,
which sits on a fibrous
substance called the Septum,
which separates the atria from the
ventricles. Okay. So, so you know,
the hardest kind of tilted to one side,
right?
It's not straight up and down so that
the atria are up here and the ventricles
are down here. There's a, there's
a, there's a Septum in between.
And that's where this Aav node sits
and it turns out that this Septum is
electrically insulating.
And so if a action potential,
a wave of action potential gets
generated up in the atrium,
it stops when it hits the center,
the Septum,
it doesn't move directly
to the ventricles.
So the muscles of the Atrium and the
muscles of the ventricle are electrically
isolated.
The only point of connection between
them is this specialized fiber pathway
called the Ab node.
And that Aav node leads into a series
of branching fibers that are called the
Perkin g system per Kinji
fibers down here, Pur,
k, I, N, g, e, and um, and these,
these are fibers that very rapidly
conduct action potentials are electrical
signals.
Okay?
Okay.
What I want you to see in this slide is
to notice that while all of these cells
are excitable, they have
the property of, of uh,
of generating and sustaining
an action potential.
They're excitable that
an action potential,
it can be generated in though the
shape of the action potential varies in
different cells.
And that's all this diagram shows you
and you don't need to know the details,
but notice that some things are
different. For example, in the essay node,
it's a very slow rise of potential
followed by a slow fall and then a much
slower rise again compared to
ventricular muscle, for example,
that has a very rapid uptake,
a sustained depolarisation phase,
and then a rapid repolarization
back to baseline.
So there are differences in
the ways that these things, uh,
undergo action potentials.
What do you think that's based on?
What's different about these cells?
Okay,
well, if the action potential is the
result of these voltage gated channels,
that must mean that ventricular muscle
cells have a different set of voltage
gated channels than essay node cells.
And they might have totally different
molecules that are doing the transport or
they might just have different numbers
of these molecules in their membranes.
But that's the difference in physiology.
What we're going to get to by the end
here is I'm going to try to convince you
that this,
this,
these changes that are occurring
in individual myocytes,
this rush of current that underlies the
action potential generation is what we
measure when we measure an EKG.
That what you're measuring is sort
of the sum of all of these electrical
potentials that are occurring as your
heartbeat changes in electrical pin
because your,
your heart cells are all experiencing
changes in electrical potential.
And because your body is basically a
salt solution which conducts electricity,
that you can measure those changes in
electrical potential happening in cells in
the heart by having electrodes just
on the surface of your skin. Okay?
And so the EKG arises from all of these
action potentials that are happening
within all of the thousands
of cells within your heart.
This diagram is a little
easier to understand. It
had more words than I liked,
so I blocked some of them out.
Uh,
but the other ones are things that
we've already talked about before.
The essay node is now familiar to you.
The sinoatrial node,
the node, this specialized
bundle of his which carries,
uh, which carries, um, uh, potential, uh,
action potentials very quickly from the
Ab node down to the Perkin g system and
the Perkin g system, which, uh, which
branches throughout the ventricular wall.
So how does is a heartbeat regulated?
It turns out that some of these cells are
capable of generating their own action
potentials.
They don't need to be distilled,
mutilated by some outside disturbance.
They generate an action
potential on their own. And the,
and the most famous of these is the
essay node up here and the essay node.
If you look at it, here's the
action potential in the essay node.
Deep polarization repolarization.
Now look what happens here. The, the,
the s the cell when most membranes
we've talked about are at resting state
resting state such that their membrane
potential stays constant until is
disturbed by something from outside.
This cell actually is change
slowly changing its membrane
potential on its own.
And it does that with a very,
uh,
with a very consistent frequency such
that at some point this slow rise of
action potential is going to,
this slow rise of membrane potential is
going to go high enough that it causes
its own disturbance and causes
its own action potential.
This is called a self propagating
action potential cells,
like cells of the SCA node,
they're capable of doing this,
have special properties of
their, um, of their ion channels.
But the end result is that the essay
node is just making potentials on a very
regular basis.
And if you measured,
if you put an electrode or if you shrunk
yourself and you had your magic boots
and you could stand on the essay node,
you would measure an action potential
about, uh, 60 times a minute.
Once a second. The essay node is
just creating an action potential.
Now when it creates that action potential,
what happens?
It disturbs the cells that are
around it, right? When the,
when the essay node creates
an action potential,
it causes a voltage disturbance in the
cells around it and they start making
action potentials. And starting
from this source in the essay node,
a wave of action potential starts to
move over the atrium over the atria.
First,
the right and then the left.
And what happens as this wave of action
potential spreads over the Atria,
what happens? What else do
muscle cells do? They contract.
And so a self propagating action potential
in the essay node induces an action
potential wave that spreads over
the Atria, the atria contract,
and they can tract,
if you watched them,
they can tract from the
region of the essay.
Note out to the right
slightly before the left,
but it passes pretty fast over these
relatively small surface areas.
Now remember that there's a Septum in
between the atria and the ventricles.
So the, so the, the,
the this action potential wave would
stop and not go down to the ventricle
except for the Aav node.
When the action potential comes down,
these pathways,
these specialized pathways
from the essay note,
it reaches the Ab node and the Ab node
has another special property in that when
it's stimulated to make an
action potential, it hesitates.
It hesitates for a fraction of a second.
And then it starts its own action
potential. So it receives the disturbance,
it waits, and then it makes
its own action potential.
And so what happens when you start
to put the picture together? Now,
essay node action, potential wave
of action potential of the Atria,
contraction of the Atria, ab
node gets the signal, waits,
generates an action potential,
and that action potential
quickly propagates down
through the bundle of his and
the Perkin g system.
And what do they do?
They carry this action potential
down into the ventricles.
They start action
potentials in the ventricle,
which then pass as a wave
over the ventricular muscle.
And after that wave of action potentials
comes contraction and ventricular
contraction.
Now why does the Ab node wait?
It weights in order to
control the heartbeat in the
way that we described last
time so that you want the atria to
contract and deliver their blood to the
ventricles before the
ventricle starts to contract.
You want the ventricle to wait until
it's filled up with blood from the atrial
contraction and then start to contract.
And so the AB node provides
that separation in time
of the atrial contractions
and the ventricle to contractions. Now,
how would you like the Ben Trick it?
Now remember when the ventricle
contracts, it's a big contraction, right?
And wants to force
blood in what direction?
Up Out of the top right.
That's where the pulmonary artery and the
aorta are there member from the model,
they're up at the top of the heart and
so you would like for this muscle to very
effectively eject blood out
of the ventricular chambers
and into these two large
vessels.
You all have roommates.
True.
I don't know if you all share
toothpaste with your roommates,
but if you do then some fraction of you
probably about half are irritated with
your roommates because they grab
the toothpaste tube at the top.
You might have brothers
and sisters who do this,
they grab it near the top and they squeeze
it cause they only care about getting
their little toothpaste out.
Right? And so you get this.
That's not an effective way
to get toothpaste out, right?
Squeezing it from the top because some
of the energy goes down into the bottom
and forces this toothpaste down here.
And the thing gets all out of shape.
What if you wanted to,
what if you wanted to get all of the
toothpaste out of the tube on one squeeze?
How would you do it?
Yeah,
you, you go from the bottom up, right?
You start squeezing from the bottom
and you'd squeeze it up. And,
and if you were good at this and
you could practice this at home,
you could get toothpaste and you
could see how much of the, how,
what fraction you can get out
with a single squeeze. And you,
I think you'd find your best is to start
from the bottom and squeeze sort of
systematically going up. And that's
what the heart does. And that's why the,
this Perkin g system is here to rapidly
conduct sig alerts from the essay,
know down to the base of the ventricle
and really start to contraction down here
so that the contraction
starts at the, uh, at the, uh,
at the bottom and squeezes up
and the blood is propelled out.
Okay.
So one of the roles of the Perkin g
system is to carry this potential into the
ventricles in a way that provides maximum
benefit from the contraction of the
cells that result.
Okay.
Now a couple of other things that
are interesting to know here.
One is it the essay node is not,
the only is not the only collection of
cells in the heart that are capable of
generating their own action potentials.
Actually,
the Ab node is also capable of
generating the action potential,
and so are the cells
in the Perkin g system.
They all can generate action potentials,
but it turns out that the essay,
no does it the fastest.
It does it at about 60 beats per minute.
The AAV node does it.
It maybe 40 beats per minute
and the Perkin g fibers do it.
It even a lower rate than that.
So what does that mean?
It means if the essay node
is functioning properly,
the Ab node doesn't matter what it's
doing in terms of automatic generation of
potentials because that potential that
was first generated by the essay note
arrives at the Aav node before it
generates its own potential, right?
So who determines the heart rate?
The fastest beating, automatic sell.
And those are generally in the essay node.
What happens if,
if you have a disease in your
essay node and it stops functioning
than the Aav node will take over it
because it's no longer being stimulated by
the essay nodes, action potential
and the wave that results,
it will start beating,
but the heart will beat slower.
It will be at 40 beats per minute,
let's say.
And if you had some disease there and that
didn't work any more than the Perkins,
he says so. So the, the
heart has sort of a,
a fail safe system built in such that
if this automatic beat generator fails,
there are inferior,
not such good quality but still capable
be generators further down the line.
Often those, uh, the Ab node itself,
you're not going to be able to function
the same way because you're not going to
get the same cardiac output because your
heart isn't beating fast enough, right?
And so, uh, there are ways
to treat that now and the,
and the most common way of treating
that is by putting a pacemaker into the
heart.
And the pacemaker is a device designed
by biomedical engineers about the size of
a hockey puck, but now even smaller
than that, that sits in your chest.
And it basically does what
the essay notice supposed
to do generates a potential
with a very regular period.
And there's a wire that goes from the,
this artificial device into your heart,
into the atrial muscle and sits there and
stimulates the tissue around the essay
node, uh, to replace its function,
right? So that's how a pacemaker works.
And this technology has evolved to the
point where there's sort of wireless, uh,
you can, you can send signals
in, you can change the rate,
you can reprogram the pacemaker without
having to take it out and actually
physically reprogram it.
So these are quite sophisticated
engineering devices now.
Um, I said something about action
potentials and ion currents. I'm,
I'm not gonna say anything
more about that. Um,
now I will say that in,
in neurons what is important
in a propagation of an
action potential is sodium
and potassium. But in muscle
cells, calcium is also a
much more important player.
And the reason that calcium is a much
more important player is as you will learn
if you study more physiology,
calcium is the most important,
Ian in terms of initiating contraction.
And so movement of calcium around
muscle cells is very important.
And this just shows, uh, shows an
action potential in for example,
of ventricular cell. It has
this rapid upstroke, this, uh,
this plateau in depolarization
in this recovery.
So this might be an action potential you'd
record from a ventricular muscle cell.
And if at the same time you were recording
this action potential and you were
also measuring contraction.
So think of this measurement as how
much contraction the cell has done.
At this point,
it's in its resting state.
And this points in his most contracted
state than the contraction follows the
action potential by about a
hundred milliseconds. Right?
So as the contraction happens,
as the action potential happens,
the contraction happens about a hundred,
150 milliseconds after that,
the maximum response. But these
things are coupled, right?
But they're not simultaneous.
Okay.
MMM.
I think, um, I've, uh, covered
what's shown in this slide here.
This is just a simpler version
of what we've talked about.
Generation of the cysts of the signal in
the essay node movement to the Avm node,
hesitation and then movement of
this signal down the, um, the,
the Septum in between the left and the
right ventricle through the Perkin g
system and the heartbeat being
generated in this, uh, in this, uh,
in this regular anatomical pattern.
And that happens because these specialized
tissues are able to conduct signal's
very rapidly.
And you can see here in this slide,
this is how fast to signal the velocity
of an action potential being propagated
through different tissues.
It goes very rapidly through pathways,
like through the atrium,
through the bundle of hist and very
rapidly through the Perkin g system.
And that's why the signal gets transmitted
so rapidly from the Ab node down to
the base of the heart.
Yeah.
These,
these diagrams are in the powerpoints
which are posted and I just encourage you
to look at them together with reading
the chapter and hopefully that will help
you to understand this process,
which brings us back to thinking at the
end about what I've talked about several
times during the lecture.
That is that you can measure something
about the physiology of the heart by
measuring all of this electrical activity.
And one way to measure it would be to put
electrodes directly into the heart and
physically put them right near the site
of action and measure exactly what's
happening.
And that could be,
you could get a very detailed picture of
what's happening in the heart that way
and that can be done. Uh, but that's
uh, that's an invasive process.
Their cardiologists that do that,
they do this every day on people.
They put a catheter into your heart,
a catheter that goes through one of the
vessels and artery in your leg. It's,
it's uh,
it's pushed up into the heart.
And then there are recording electrodes
on the end and they can image measure
electrical activity directly in
the heart at different locations.
That's called cardiac catheterization
and cardiac electrophysiology.
And it's widely used to, uh, to
diagnose disease in the heart.
That's usually not the first thing you
do because that's an invasive procedure,
right? What is important about
EKG is that it's noninvasive.
You can do it without entering the
body by just measuring something that's
happening on the surface.
And you can do it very simply by placing
electrodes at different positions on
the body.
And you've all seen a,
a diagram like this that shows
a typical trace of an EKG.
It's measured in millivolts here.
It's a relatively small potential, right?
Because, because there's some distance,
you know,
the potentials that were
actually generated in the
heart are tens of millivolts,
but you're measuring at a distance away.
And so that signal has been attenuated.
You're only measuring fractions of
a millivolt. Um, at the surface,
but what you see is a little bump followed
by a followed by a delay followed by
a very big wave followed by a delay
followed by one and sometimes two smaller
waves. Right? This is the
signal that you see, um,
that you've seen on a,
on a screens by patient's
beds and countless movies
and television shows, right?
What does, what do these represent? Well,
they're called by letters of the alphabet.
This one's called the p
wave that represents the
activity caused during atrial
contraction.
So all of those currents
that are generated during
atrial contractions show up
as a p wave.
The QRS complex,
this very big signal here is
contraction of the ventricle.
And so what does this represent here?
The distance between the p wave and the,
and the QRS wave.
This represents the delay in signal
transmitting through the Ab node.
So if you're ab node was not functioning,
you'd expect that to shorten,
right?
That that lag would shorten.
And you'd also expect that your cardiac
performance would not be so good because
you don't have this delay. Then
the venture coal is, is, uh,
is contracting before it's fully filled
by the atrial contractions, right?
And you can diagnose that perhaps somebody
comes in, they're short of breath,
they're having trouble, uh, uh, they don't
know what it is. You measure their EKG,
you see that there,
this,
this is shortened and you know that
there's a problem with their cardiac
conduction system in
particular with the Ab node.
That's how physicians use these
tools. Uh, the t wave is re polar is,
is,
is repolarization of the ventricles.
So this is that this is the return of
all of this current back into the cell
after this massive depolarization.
And the you wave,
which is only very rarely seen,
represents a relaxation of the muscles,
the papillary muscles inside, which
controls some of the valve function. Uh,
but, um, um,
we'll talk about this more in a
section. Uh, if you've had a full,
you'll know that they put many
electrodes on your, on your body.
They put a full electrocardiograph would
take a 12 electrodes and some of them
are placed on your limbs and some of
them are placed around your chest,
sort of wrapped around
your chest in a fashion.
And the reason for doing
that is that you can,
if you put several electrodes,
then you could look at the potential
difference that's generated by looking at
any two of those electrodes.
And if I have one up here and one up here,
and I look at the voltage difference here,
it might not be the same as the voltage
difference measure between here and here.
And why is that?
Because your heart is oriented in space.
It's a three dimensional object and all
of these cells are at particular three
dimensional positions inside
this three dimensional object.
And as these currents happen,
they happen in a very
spatially oriented way.
And so the potential difference I
measure at a distance here and here for
example,
is different.
And it's sort of like looking at the
heart from different vantage points,
right?
Looking at the electrical activity of
the heart from different vantage points.
And so one of the things
that cardiologists have
learned how to do is how to
look at potentials that are generated
from different spatial locations and
correlate that with things
that are happening over the
complex geography of the
heart. So why do you have
more than one electrode?
It's so you can look at the heart
from sort of different angles.
Okay. Okay. Questions?
Good.
See you on Thursday.